foreign
all right so
um
just observing you in classroom it looks
like something's off a little bit and so
I've asked uh officer Dean to come in
here and visit with it has you you know
um have you taken anything that's
you know do you have a prescription for
anything that maybe you have taken today
that just seems like you're not the same
person that I talked to this morning
um I did take a I did take some
medication last night to to help me with
sleep because I have some anxiety stuff
but that's
that's
I can't think of the name of it right
now but I could look it up when I get
home
She haven't taken anything while you
were at school no
um
you know one thing I would tell you is
um you know for your appointment I want
you to be truthful okay and so
um
would you be willing to take a
breathalyzer test
if I needed to yeah
you don't have to but if you're willing
to do it that helps us
have you taken any sort of medication
today I'm sorry have you taken any
medication today
I did take some medication this morning
for my anxiety what did you take this
morning
um I think it's called
um
um quozepin I'm not I'm not very good
you take it here at school
I took it yeah I took it this morning
while you're here
yeah right before I came in yes
okay is it a prescription because you've
changed your story a little bit now yeah
well I took one last night and then I
took one this morning because my anxiety
was really like like that well that's
understandable so what time did you take
it
this morning whenever you took it last
what time was that
uh
uh where's it at in your car in your
classroom no I had one I took it in my I
put it in my pocket and then I took it
you put in your pocket
yeah yeah because I didn't want to bring
the whole bottle in you do know that if
it's a narcotic you have to have it in a
bottle right or you can be charged with
it
I do not know that yeah it's going to be
in the prescription bottle
so just I want you to understand that I
care very much about you okay and I just
I need to make sure you're okay
I need to make sure that you're safe and
I've got to make sure that the kids are
safe so
we're just trying to help you and make
sure everything's okay okay because this
is
um your demeanor like I told you earlier
is just a lot
it's a lot different so if there is
anything that you need
I'm having a hard time with some
depression stuff and I
um
did you drink something while you were
here at school
not while I was at school
when did you drink something
last night
not here at school because it seemed
that it changed I mean your demeanor
kind of changed
being here at school
oh I wouldn't bring him into the school
okay
are you gonna blow double zeros
I don't know you should know if you
hadn't drink anything you should blow
zeros
if you drank something recently or it's
going to show it
I'll just run out
you should now I couldn't think that you
are not going to
okay so what's going to happen I'm not
going to do anything with you well I'm
asking Mrs
well I'm just going to be honest
Kimberly I'm concerned about you I have
a responsibility to take care of the
kids right and it's not going to be my
decision
it's my decision so let's see what
happens all right all right so you're
gonna blow into like you're blowing up a
balloon okay and you're gonna keep
blowing Thai Thai style until I tell you
to stay until I tell you to stop okay
all right all right give it a second
I I don't know how to do this you're
just going to blow into it like you're
blowing up a blunt as soon as I tell you
all right ready take a big deep breath
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah all right good job
[Applause]
you gonna tell me the truth how much you
have to drink
there's no way you drank last night well
I did drink
I didn't drink at school
that wouldn't blow that right there
you blew two times the legal limit I did
yeah
here's our drink that you have what's in
this drink
that's a Diet Coke is there anything
liquor in it nope
so if I go into the classroom am I gonna
find anything else
if we go out and search your car no
so where did the liquor come from did
you leave campus
not today
have you
this thing is pretty accurate No I know
it is so I know it is
he blew like a 0.24
I don't know what that means legal
limits 0.08
do you drink often
unfortunately yes okay yeah I'm not
trying to insult you I'm just trying to
understand why no I I I'm seeing a
counselor I'm seeing a counselor about
you have had anything to drink today
your expert opinion she's under the
influence
well I mean
you are my honest opinion I think she's
probably a functioning alcoholic
when she below that she could and be
normal in life before not drink today
well no no because she's had to have
drank sometime today
like even it was at 3am do you want to
blow one more time on a different straw
to see if it changes yeah I want you all
to tell me what I have to do
I just want you to be honest
yeah
I'm seeing the counselor for my stuff
so do you live here in town I live in I
live in Stillwater
do you have anybody that's there that
could come pick you up
uh
my husband's so he's still at school
working
um contact your eyes do what can I check
your eyes yeah
come on stand up
[Applause]
I'm not gonna go through the entire test
but
stay with your feet by your side hands
down to your
feet side to side feel to Hell there you
go all right
let's just follow the tip of my pan your
eyes are as well when do you understand
you've drank recently
yeah she was intoxicated
I see
um do you know your husband's number if
I call him
I I don't want you to call me well I
can't let you leave if you leave you're
gonna get arrested yeah I'm gonna rush
it for DUI
so I need somebody to come pick you up
I just I
I know I've been having a hard time I
just
am I gonna get fired just honestly yes
or you can resign
you're under the influence at school
with kids
that cannot happen
I I
all right
can I not just be that it's in my blood
system and that's why unless you were
drink a ton well I feel like eight
o'clock this morning I don't think I
don't know how you could still be that
hot
I did drink a lot last night how much
did you drink well I don't
too much what what do you drink
wine
so how many bottles of wine did you
drink
uh we had the blocks
did you drink all bottles of wine
half a box
and you stopped drinking at like three
times
the problem is is they said you were
fine this morning and then
now after recently they've noticed a
difference
that's weird to me
that's
which makes me think that you you've
drank recently
I would I would think
so your options are
we call somebody to pick you up you come
visit me tomorrow
two you get
I won't even let you get your vehicle
I'll just arrest you right now for
Publican talks
just don't do that then you should
probably find a ride
can I can I make that happen myself
right now
do I have to do it and right here
yes we need to know somebody yeah we're
not leaving he's not gonna leave here
until somebody picks you up
so either you leaving a vehicle or you
live in my vehicle one of the two
for who are we calling
I don't know
I'm I'm sorry I'm just I'm having a hard
time
so who do you go home to your husband
so why can't we call your husband
I don't want you to I don't want you to
have to call him
well he's either gonna come here and
pick it or he's going to take you to the
police station well I don't want that to
happen either well then you got to
figure this out we're not going to do
this run around either you make the
decision I'll make it for you and you'll
be walked out of here in handcuffs
okay I don't okay then we need to call
someone
I'm not trying to be a jerk but we can't
find this no I know
we don't have all day free to make a
decision
I'm not trying to be like that I'm just
I'm just I'm I'm just
I'm
okay you got one minute
tell me a number we're gonna call or
we're trying to let you at least have
some dignity and not walk out of here in
front of everybody no yes so if you let
us call somebody we'll wait they can
come wait outside everybody's gone we'll
tell them to be here at 4 30 and
you'll be able to leave the building by
seeing but if we're we don't have time
to keep doing this no I I understand I'm
sorry I don't mean to be
kind of I'm trying
so if if we call somebody to come and
get me so then what happens after that
then you're going to meet me tomorrow at
my office and we'll discuss your
appointment
what what time tomorrow
9 A.M
so so what happens so what happens then
Mr Ogle well my recommendation to the
board is going to be determined to you
because you're under the influence
or you can resign
you you won't give me like a second
chance or anything
no
not in this situation
your stories change two or three times I
don't think you're personally being
honest with this uh
what
we think that you drank today not 3 A.M
we think that you've drank since you've
been at school
and I don't believe you being honest
with us
do you want to change that story
no I
I mean
even if I did does that make it does
that make a difference to to work here I
I would help me to be able to understand
that maybe you know maybe you don't need
to be sympathetic with you a little bit
I just don't believe you right now I
think you're lying to this
okay I drank on the way to work
I I I'm glad that you told us that okay
we'll still discuss tomorrow I I went to
work here I
well
um so tomorrow at nine o'clock now let's
call somebody and come pick you up
do you have anyone else you can call you
have a friend that you got picked yet
I don't know
would you rather call your husband to
come pick you up would you rather call
your husband to come get you from jail
well actually neither well I mean you've
got it you're running out of time
um
okay I'll call I'll call somebody
I'm sorry I don't I don't mean to to to
to waste your your time or anything like
that I'm I'm sorry
I just want someone to come pick you up
so I don't have to humility by walking
out no I don't no please don't do that
that's awesome we need a number right
now to call or I'm done
okay
okay so give me your number who am I
calling I I don't I don't have up my
heart where's your phone at
it's in the classroom
can they go
can I go again you can't no
no you can't no I will lift let me see
if I can get
what'd you drink this morning
I don't drink anything but wine okay
can I call you back
all right
so you drink wine here on the way to the
school this morning
I didn't drink
or anything
okay I'm gonna go to your room where is
your phone can I go down there with you
I don't even
[Music]
I think it's in my purse but the purse
is where
can I please can I no there's Kids in
the Hall and there's teachers all
standing here they don't even know
you're in here
it might be on the desk it's on the desk
is there any alcohol or anything
I don't think so I don't know I
don't know
hey Doug
how often do you go see a counselor
[Applause]
once every other week
is it helping at all
no it was and then it wasn't
I'm not saying you're a bad person or
anything I understand people build their
stuff
it's all right
it's
it's and I'm not trying to humiliate you
I don't want to humiliate you I
understand people your stuff probably go
in your life I have nothing know nothing
about
I'm just trying to figure out what's
going on
you don't have time to hear all about us
how long have you been in teaching yeah
um I've worked with kids my whole life
is this your first year to actually be a
teacher
no I I thought it was when I thought it
had started I'm so sorry I let everybody
down I'm sorry
I'm sure you've heard metal though
I hear it all the time some people
actually mean it though some people
don't
no more games right
my juice
I'm gonna try again
that layer is wine
well it's from yesterday
are you drinking up here yesterday
from home
did you get my phone this in here
well I mean is my phone in here
I didn't go through your bag
I know but my thing is yeah
did you get my phone you said your phone
was in the purse
are you gonna call someone
well I don't I I don't I used to have
everybody's numbers but
you're gonna get your phone and call
someone what is it not in there photo is
on the desk
it's on the desk
[Applause]
being truthful goes a long ways and you
haven't done it yet
[Music]
[Applause]
it's kind of half-minded I rush you just
because you lied to me
okay what do I need to do to make
everything right I just wanted honesty
that's all I wanted I I drank out of
that yesterday I didn't break out of it
today
I don't believe you I I drank out of
that coming to work yesterday
well where where's the cup that you
drank out of today
is it in your classroom too I don't
I don't think so
honestly I
I thought I was doing a good job today I
don't know I I don't know
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
and then you wipe this out
but
please let me please let me go I should
charge you a tampering with evidence
please let me no no it is over
no more no more I'm done officer please
no I've never done anything my whole
life what is your date of birth
by 1970 please let me call somebody
please I will call somebody right now
I I've got a friend right here you know
in Perkins no you're under arrest please
don't do this it's too late no please
please please I can't do this please
please officer please please
please no
please
bullet please
[Applause]
two four two eight
peace 20428
please you're under arrest we're not
there's no getting out of it no no let
me call you said I could call somebody
I'll call
police it's too late
why is it too late all of a sudden
because you've lied nothing but lie
well that's because I have a problem
obviously but please to afford to it no
officer please I have a friend that just
lives right down the street she'll come
get me please
please let me just call it no
you said I could call somebody can you
guys not hear me
I need someone to come down here and
transport for me you were Dylan
[Applause]
[Music]
are you
okay
uh I don't care just
uh
we'll go out the back door over here
like by the playground
yeah
yeah all right
officer
please
please no and what really pisses me off
to
to top it off as you wipe that out to
try to cover it up
um 10 15 with a teacher for papia
I do I can't get owls I can't get out I
guess I've been asking for Dylan or
Spencer to come transport for me
I want to have uh Spencer come in the
back way and I'll take her uncle back
away oh my God
she's lied and lied and Mr oboe found a
cup that had wine residue in it on her
desk so
uh something coats she's a new teacher
um I'm in Miss balls's office
but I'm trying not to totally humiliate
this lady but she's
she's working on it because she keeps
she wiped the cup out
so
yep
yeah I'll take her out that way like out
back like by the playground
wait
all right
all right where's your driver's license
at
I don't know
where's the deal you're under arrest so
hey we're not gonna sit here and whine
it's that's over
[Applause]
am I gonna find anything illegal in here
I don't think so
famous words
[Applause]
I'm sorry officer Dean please please
don't do this
please I where's your wallet
is your first name Kimberly is that your
legal first name is your driver's
license or Oklahoma yes please don't
arrest me please let me just call a
friend to come and get me I'll call a
friend I'll do whatever I have to but
please don't arrest me please hello
please don't do this please hello
hello
in just a second
all right here's the deal stand up
you're under arrest I'm gonna Place
handcuffs on the front of you in front
of you no no no no no
no no no no
you're gonna come you might have to come
in here
Maybe
no
no I'm in Miss ballz's office
can you let them in Mr Ogle's gonna come
let you in
yeah Outback
all right
stand up
stand up can you just no I said I'm done
no just no can I just walk out without
the hand no no please just let me look
out no it's policy I'm not gonna I'm
like I'm gonna cuff you up front If
You're Gonna Keep
running your mouth you're gonna get
caught behind you wait can I just talk
to you for a second please at least put
your hands behind your back
no I don't want to
you want to go to jail no multiple
charges no put your hands behind your
back please don't do this please
I want to talk to you can you just talk
to me put your hands behind your back
we've I've tried talking to you
talking's over
what about my stuff
it'll go with you to the gym
all right
quit I'm done
I tried to be nice
I'm done okay
[Applause]
can I just please no can I just ask you
a question nope questions are over
why is this your phone yes
what made you so mad at me
you're so mad
what made you so mad I don't want to
please don't do this to me
please
I'm trying not to
so we're just going there for just a
second please I'm sorry
stop
pulling away from me I don't need a
bullet weight I'm just
I'm really good I'm not saying you are
can't we just no talking's over
you've done nothing but lie did not
listen
oh no can't you just give me another no
another chance is over please please
please please
no no no no no
please don't let me go out and go right
this way and then go around back to the
cafeteria yeah
I do need her keys to the building uh
there's some there's some keys in here
I'll come back and get that I see it I
got a runner a ticket soon
future
yeah
they're so cute
hey it's over you had your chances
[Applause]
you've done nothing but lie and then you
wipe the cup out to try to hide your
evidence
[Applause]
at this point it doesn't really matter
well it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
why does it matter you didn't care when
you came to school drunk or drank at
school I didn't drink at school I told
you I'd drink well you had a gup a cup
of wine on your desk in your classroom
yesterday
[Applause]
there
um
thank you for taking me around this way
this one
he's gonna look in her bag there's some
keys in her bag I just went over the
school case that's uh do you have
anything in your pockets
uh where's my ID and
that's to my classroom hey Mr Ogle
[Applause]
oh that's my that's my uh
fish fish
[Music]
all right stand right here
thank you
what are you looking for we put that in
her bag it was in her Pockets fish
we give that to Mr Robot is that a
school key are there any school keys on
this no that's my that's my Airbnb
that's all
we'll see
hey Spencer if I write a ticket can you
run it back up there here a little bit
you were doing yeah oh yeah okay never
mind I'm gonna do a district
foreign